a hash-table is used to implement
associative arrays or mappings of key
value pairs hash tables are a common way
to implement the map data structure or
objects they are widely used because of
how efficient they are the average time
for each lookup is not tied to the
number of elements stored in the table
in fact the average time complexity of
hash tables and big notation is o of 1
for a search insert and delete that's
very fast the way a hash table works is
that it takes a key input and then runs
it through a hash function a hash
function basically just Maps strings to
numbers and usually the numbers just
correspond to indexes in an array so for
example here are the strings we pass
through the hash function and then we
get the numbers over here a hash
function needs to be consistent so when
you run a key through the hash function
it always gives the same number and it
should map different words to different
numbers if two words get hashed to the
same number this is called a collision
you can see in this example John Smith
gets hashed to two Lisa Smith gets
hashed to what was either one Sam dofor
and then Sandra D also gets hashed to
two so this is a collision because both
these names once they run through the
hash function get turned into the same
number or the same index for the array
one way to handle collisions is just to
store both key value pairs at that index
then upon lookup of either you would
have to iterate through the bucket of
items to find the key you are looking
for this could take a little extra time
because of the iteration so here's
another example where it's showing that
the names are going through the hash
function and then it's showing basically
the information that's being stored in
the bucket so this would be the array
index and then in that array index or
the bucket we would store the phone
number so this would be like a phone
book the numerical value from the hash
function is then you
and the index to store that information
then if you try to access the same key
again the hashing function will process
the key and return the same numerical
result which will then be used to look
up the associate value which just means
that once you store all these things in
the array once you want to get the
number again you would just pass in the
key John Smith into the hash function it
would give you the exact same array
index too and then you would get the
information returned to you which is the
phone number
now you will probably never have to
implement hash tables yourself because
most languages including Java Script
already have them built-in in JavaScript
hash tables are usually used to
implement objects however it can be
helpful to see how they are implemented
just to gain a better understanding so
I'm going to show you the code for a
hash table so you can see how they work
first of all we have our hash function
where we're gonna pass in the string
that we want to hash and then the Max
Max is the number of buckets that we're
using in our hash table to store values
we're gonna start with hash being 0 and
we are going to for each character in
the string string that length for as
long as the string is we are going to
add the care code of each character each
string character has a numerical value
associated with it so basically we're
just adding up the character codes for
each character in the string and putting
into the hash now instead of returning
the hash we're gonna return hash modulus
maths that just means we are going to
divide by the number of buckets and then
return the remainder so if we had 5
buckets if we're divided by 5 the
remainder is either there going to be 0
1 2 3 or 4 and then that would be the
index that we're going to place the item
into the array now this is a very simple
hash function just for an example but
they can get much more complicated now
let's go into the hash table function so
in the hash table function we're gonna
have our storage array which is where
we're gonna store all that data we're
putting
to it and the storage limit now this is
the number of buckets in the array at
first I'm just gonna show you with just
four different buckets but normally
actually this number would be much
higher and this is just a utility
function just for this example so I can
easily print all the items in this
storage array I can easily log them so
here's where the real methods come in
for the hash table if we want to add
some information so first you're gonna
pass in a key and a value we're gonna
figure out the index of the array by
running it through the hash function so
we create this hash function where we're
gonna pass in the key and the storage
limit the number of buckets that we're
gonna have in our hash table and that's
going to return an index that we went
over before if there's nothing in that
index in the storage array if it's
undefined we're just going to set the
index to be this key value pair array
else if it's not undefined that means
there's already something in that bucket
so first we're gonna set insert it to
false and then we're gonna go through
each index to see if the key already
exists if the key already exists we're
gonna set the new value here and set
insert the true if the key does not
exist then insert is still gonna be
equal to false so we're going to push in
the new item that's where we'll get
multiple entries into one bucket so the
next thing is if we're going to remove
an item from the hash table so if we're
gonna remove you're just passing the key
of what you want to remove and now we're
gonna look up the index by passing it
into the hash function if the index that
length equals one that means there's
only going to be one item in that bucket
and the item in that bucket equals the
key that you passed in then you can just
delete that index you can just sleep
that item
but if it does not equal one that means
there's probably a few different items
at that index and we want to only delete
the item associated with that key so
we're going to go through each item in
that bucket or in the
next and if the key equals the key we
passed in then we can delete that item
the zero index is the key the one index
is the value so let's go how we would
look up an item again we're gonna set
the index using our hash function with
the key that we passed in and the
storage limit if the index there is
undefined we just return undefined it's
not the item is not in the hash table
else we're going to go through each
element in that bucket if the element
equals the key then we can return that
element so let's look at a few examples
first I'm going to show you an example
of the hash function here if we run that
for me three and every time I run that
you'll see in the console three three
three every time I put Bo it's gonna put
three but if I put a different name here
and I run that you can see on the
console it's gonna be five and now every
time I run that's gonna be five so with
this hash function it's going to always
be a number between zero and nine
because we're passing in ten as the
number of buckets so now let's actually
see the hash table so here we're gonna
create a new hash table called hte for a
hash table we're gonna add Bo who's a
person and find out it was a dog retsu
the dinosaur tux who's a penguin then
we're gonna look up tux and then we're
just gonna print the entire thing so
let's see what happens in the console so
we saw that tux is a penguin now let me
bring this over a little bit it's going
to show our entire half state well not
normally you're never gonna print out
the hash table like I did to the console
but I just did that just for learning
purposes if you remember up here we have
the storage limit set up for so we only
have four buckets the reason why I had
it set up for is so we'll see what it
looks like when there's a collision when
there's two things in one bucket just by
coincidence the first buck is undefined
that means none of these words hashed to
zero and then if we look at the second
bucket that's right here there's
actually two key value pairs
in the second bucket so both bow and tux
both gave one when it went through the
hash function and then you can see in
this bucket right here
we just have one item and then this
bucket right here we just have one item
so when we pass in Rex to the hash
function we got three returned but if we
go up here and we change the number of
buckets to something like 14 now I'm
gonna try running that again if you look
right here now there's a lot more
undefined because most of the buckets
are now empty but this bucket only has
one item that bug is one item and then
the last two bucks have one item and
there are no collisions now each bucket
only has one item now this has just been
a pretty simple example of a hash table
implementation but it's enough to give
you a basic idea of the hash table
thanks for watching my name is Bo Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good